what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and of course the
spider-man universe over at sony as well
and it actually looks like sony might be
doing somewhat of a reboot of their
spider-man universe and this does
include a new spider-man which is quite
interesting to think about and we'll
definitely talk in detail about this in
this video but also at the same time it
looks like marvel studios has some
pretty big plans that are already in the
works for their next spider-man trilogy
with tom holland which is great news but
it does seem like the studios really are
keeping their universes separate it
doesn't look like we are going to be
getting tom holland spider-man in the
sony spider-man universe but he is
strictly sticking to the mcu after all
the spider-man no way home post-credit
scene did set up a new venom not tom
hardy's venom from the sony universe but
a new venom in the mcu which also
implies that a new spider-man should be
coming to the sony universe as well but
what's really interesting is that sony
might actually be doing a complete reset
of their entire universe as we know it
and it all starts with madame webb so as
you can see lots to talk about in this
video so let's dive into it and of
course if you're new and you want to
stay up to date on all things marvel and
spider-man be sure to subscribe so let's
start off with the mcu's spider-man tom
holland spider-man and marvel and sony's
plans for the next trilogy now to start
off first and foremost if you are not
aware after spider-man no way home was
released kevin feige the president of
marvel studios and amy pascal an
executive producer over at sony came out
and told us that they were already
working on the next spider-man film with
tom holland they also specifically
stated that the only reason they told us
that was so we don't all freak out and
question whether or not spider-man is
actually going to remain in the mcu or
go back over to the sony spider-man
universe that's what happened after
spider-man far from home we all didn't
know if spider-man was going to remain
in the mcu so they're just coming out
and stating already yes he is and we are
working on the next films and a new
report states that they have already
begun these plans in fact these plans
actually prevented a spider-man cameo in
she-hulk which is a pretty big bummer
because the fact that we could have
gotten a spider-man cameo in she-hulk
with a daredevil cameo is pretty
disappointing especially if they could
have all actually been together imagine
seeing daredevil and spider-man together
with she-hulk that would have been
pretty dang cool and the she-hulk
writers actually wanted this to happen
however they were not allowed to use
spider-man in the she-hulk series this
report is coming from thedirect.com in
an exclusive interview with she-hulk
series creator and head writer jessica
gao and in this interview she states
that there were a lot of characters that
were from the comics that they couldn't
use because of either a rights issue or
there were a few times where it was
because marvel had something to do with
it but in this interview they actually
indirectly confirm that marvel and sony
have already begun their plans for the
next spider-man film this is what
jessica gao had to say as far as cameos
were concerned she said there were a lot
of characters from the comics we wanted
a lot of the comics for characters for
fun situations where we could bring in
like a character and think of like funny
reasons why they would be in legal
trouble but there were a lot of
characters that were from the comics
that we couldn't use either because of a
rights issue or there were a few times
where it was because marvel all they
would say is that they had other plans
and that's all they would tell us and
then we tried very very hard to poke and
prod and get a little bit more
information of course they wouldn't tell
us now as far as what character or
characters that marvel was talking about
she goes on to say but i will say the
one mcu character that really bummed out
a lot of the writers in our room that we
couldn't use was spider-man and anyone
involved around like the spider-man
universe because we had so many
spider-man fans in the room so the
she-hulk writers wanted to bring in
spider-man but were super bummed out
when marvel told them that they couldn't
now there are two reasons for this and
one is that sony simply wouldn't let
them but that's probably not it sony has
let marvel use spider-man and other
properties before properties that
weren't specifically spider-man films
granted they were big movies like
captain america civil war infinity war
and avengers end game but keep in mind
that marvel studios themselves and kevin
feige does have a lot of pool with what
spider-man does if kevin feige thought
it would be good to have spider-man and
she-hulk he would make it happen but if
we look back to what she said it's very
clear that marvel studios had other
plans for spider-man she said that there
were a few times where they wanted a
certain character but they couldn't use
them because marvel all they would say
is that they had other plans and that's
all they would tell them and then they
tried very very hard to poke and prod
and get more information but marvel
would not tell them since all of the
writers really wanted spider-man the
most it seems like i'm assuming that the
character that they were poking about
that marvel studios had other plans for
is spider-man which sucks that he can't
be in she-hulk but is also good news at
the same time in a state where we don't
really know what's happening right now
with spider-man 4 it's good to know that
marvel and sony at least have somewhat
of a plan and you would hope they do
because secret wars is not that far away
it's three years away which means
there's probably only time for one more
spider-man film maybe two if they want
to get one out really soon to take place
before secret wars happens because
spider-man is going to be a part of
secret wars we've already seen the three
spider-man together it's the perfect
opportunity to bring them together again
and add even more spider-man not
necessarily variants but spider-man like
miles morales and they could even throw
in characters like spider-man 2099 plus
not to mention they could link the venom
symbiote to secret wars as that is the
first time in the comics where we
actually see spider-man in his black
symbiote suit and marvel made it pretty
clear that the next spider-man film
should according to the post-credits
scene of no way home be about venom and
i think marvel studios probably only has
time for one more spider-man film before
we get to secret wars after all we know
we're not getting a spider-man film in
2022 we most likely won't get one in
2023 since we really haven't heard
anything about the movie yet that leaves
2024 or early 2025 to do one spider-man
film before secret wars actually before
the king dynasty because if that's going
to be an avengers film which it is
spider-man should be a part of the
avengers so i hope he shows up then now
as far as sony spider-man universe is
concerned it does look like they are
indeed getting a new spider-man which is
a very very interesting move but
basically what we know so far is that
the movie madame webb which is a
spider-man universe based movie is going
to include a baby peter parker according
to a report from the cosmic circus sony
for madame webb has cast emma roberts to
play mary parker the mother of peter
parker and based off of what we know
mary parker is supposed to be pregnant
in madame webb which means that she will
have a baby peter parker now if this is
true this means that sony will indeed be
getting a new spider-man but way down
the future unless they decide to do
somewhat of a time jump in madame webb
now they can explore the multiverse in
this movie as well after all in the
comics madame webb is a cosmic being and
she can travel between universes and in
the comics she teaches spider-man and
other spider-man very important lessons
so this baby peter parker could simply
be in another universe or sony could be
planning to kind of just start over
morbius failed very very badly recently
and we're only getting one more venom
film so a reboot of the entire
spider-man universe over at sony could
be happening which could be a good thing
or could be a really bad thing but let
me know what you think about this in the
comments down below do you think they
should reboot or do you think they
should just try to build off what they
already have let me know down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things relating to spiderman and marvel
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof